après il peut être totalement on en
pâtit et bienveillante avec les
agriculteurs mais qu'elle n'oublie pas
des quotas et des ah bon voila voila je
pense que vous pouvez faire un peu
parler d'elle aux six mois je pense
sincèrement que c'était pour le buzz et
j'ai le soir j'espère vraiment que
c'était pour le buzz parce que pour moi
c'est la dame qui a le moins d'empathie
rigide donc à va pas nous faire part
qu'elle va s'intéresser aux agriculteurs
quand elle est en tournage et kg de ses
feuilles parterre excellent et
maquilleuse qui les ramasse je sais pas
si son côté très humain va servir à quoi
[Musique]
je préfère le dire pour les gens ah bah
voilà alors on va voir le sondage temps
karine lemarchand clatot midi de
mercredi au siège 4 jamais à 80% bon bah
je crois que la messe et du théâtre ce
soir sur ces 8 on vous propose une
soirée exceptionnelle juste après à
prendre ou à laisser
ce sera ensemble à l'olympia n'ont pas
les acquis mais c'est vrai nom mais ils
sont pas les dents et publics renchérit
on va on va venir vous voir vous faites
un baby-foot la personne t2 publique
notent les observateurs
ces observateurs mais sympathique même
bien merci mais là on vous aime beaucoup
voilà il a parce que vous savez pourquoi
je voulais une appli coloris parce que
je voulais quand même vous avoir un
petit peu avec moi
voilà c'est mignon